diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
bergheim und cremiger genuss seit 1922
der bundesrat hat heute entschieden die
situation als außerordentliche lage zu
erklären wie sozial
[Musik]
die einschränkung werden viele
unternehmen unzählige betrieben
angestellt und freischaffende hart
treffen
bleiben sie zu hause die regelung gilt
ab mitternacht und dauert vorerst 19
april sogar frischen wollte das ist
wirklich stehen
schock
[Musik]
die gleiche weil ich kann auch nicht
weinen
die hat keine zeit zum den konsum eine
halbzeit zum trinken
das bietet weiter schnell schmeckt wie
fein
parmaschinken 24 monate
53 dr
ich habe ganz so wenig passiert mir
besser
goodbye sagen
[Musik]
alle berge ich rate auf twitter
geschrieben
[Musik]
die zahlen sind weiter angestiegen sie
werden auch die nächsten tage sicher
weiter ansteigen
universitätsspital zürich osz in
rekordtempo werden kapazitäten aufgebaut
märz geplant dass mir immer auf die
intensiv kapazitäten des osz erweitern
und deswegen wenn jetzt quasi
die ortungsgeräte in den aufnahmen zu
verschieben das heißt einem nachbarn
natürlich wieder fassbar
bilder gefilmt von oberarzt lukas kannte
er dreht für srf in der corvette 19
abteilung des universitätsspitals aus
sicherheitsgründen sind medien nicht
zugelassen
[Musik]
unter normalen bedingungen wäre ich dort
wird sagt oberarzt tätig aufgrund der
korona situation ist ein privates
dokumentarfilmprojekt von mir
gescheitert oder zumindest auf später
verschoben
und deshalb sind wir übereingekommen
dass ich im spital filme im spital ein
dokumentarfilm über die bewältigung der
kroner situation die krone krise und was
die einzelnen mitarbeiter ratlos auf die
beine stellen
vor knapp zwei wochen werden diese räume
leer leer geräumt und nichts mehr drin
keine schraube nichts und es war eine
riesenleistung hier von allen bereichen
aus der logistik aus der administration
aus der technik diese schnell wieder
einzuräumen wurde tag und nachgearbeitet
alle haben an einem strick gezogen so
nach alle unsere vorbereitung da zu
hören und das wird sich jetzt
herausstellen wir gut vorbereitet sind
und was wir alles noch nicht
berücksichtigt habe
was macht dann meist so dass ich
irgendetwas ganz wichtiges vergessen
habe was jetzt einen ablauf gehört und
was jetzt in einer situation indes nicht
vergessen werden sollte vergessen wir
warten auf die welle
man sieht seinen horizont sieht man dem
tsunami wir wissen noch nicht was genau
bei unser auftritt und wissen noch nicht
wie hoch die welle sein wird wir sind
hier bereit diese intensivstation kann
innerhalb von wenigen stunden eröffnet
werden
ich nehme an sie wird diese woche
eröffnet werden
eine immobilie macht und der armee in
diesem ausmaß hat es seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg nicht mehr gegeben
soldaten des spital bataillons 66
aufgeboten per sms wie das richtig geht
kommen wir der politik gab es rund noch
glauben oder für mich hat geht dass ich
jetzt dafür locker
[Musik]
rund 5000 soldatinnen und soldaten sind
mobilisiert
[Musik]
zakopane 1 und 2 hertz kompanie
also hier kommen dann bin ich stolz auf
sie jede von ihnen hat vielleicht die
ängste was passiert mit mir
wie geht es weiter wie lange aber sein
die mutig und leisten will
das was von uns verlangt wird
[Musik]
mit der übernahme der fahne
unsere fahnen zeigen wie heute
symbolisch unsere bereitschaft den fein
welches zu bekämpfen gibt kann man nicht
sehen
und der könnte trotz der überall sein
nun ist jetzt an der zeit dass
trainierte in der tat umzusetzen
[Musik]
also dies vorgesehen dass wir uns
bereithalten müssen für jede
infrastruktur es wird es werden gesuche
gestellt diese werden schweizweit
beurteilt durch eine zentrale stelle und
dort wird entschieden wer braucht uns
und werden wir versuchen alle
bestmöglich zu helfen
[Musik]
dieter hildebrandt vom restaurant chefin
züri ich hoffe sie dass sie an einen
tisch reserviert haben führung 24
april ich habe das eigentlich nur kurz
zurück bestätigt aber natürlich oder
hier wie es geht
dass meine füße doch mehr open 24 schon
wieder offen
[Musik]
wann der betrieb jetzt zur ist steve
kroeger deller auf das kühlhaus läuft
gerade alles was man könne aber
abgestellt
aber es braucht wieder verteilt und
jeden tag wo zur ist kostet wie viel sie
zahlen nicht so genau sagen wie viel das
feld ob es ist einfach so dass mir im
geschäft die sich jeder monat mend
erwirtschaften lohnstückkosten und alles
können abstecken und dass man jetzt
machen die ich mir für eine formel für
den sommer kommt durch abgesagt 50
dass noch viele geben aber sie schien
euro für emirates fliegt im moment ich
muss nur gelöst was sie im home-office
bringen's buch zu dem sie in der mitte
axa versichert die gute lösung finden
für kambodscha singer partei ja stimmt
sie beabsichtigt quarantäne motive zwar
enthält wochen erwartet
die ganze geschichte wegen kurzarbeit
die sind ebenfalls tor vorbereitet
zwar heißt in madrid lauf nimmt ist der
flug der flug sind sie der abklärung
versteht man mit ihnen nicht so schnell
wie möglich bescheid im analyse kinder
ist das ist das so gut für sie
die erlöse konnte sie nichts mehr
aber keine entspannung
er sitzt im transit aus passion auf die
botschaft in madrid
ich denke außerdem fall wie jetzt york
auch wirklich schwierig voraussetzung
ist machen
wer sich mal bitte botschaft in madrid
meldet mit mainz über verschiedene
flughäfen zurückbringen oder bis
direktflügen energie kostet aktuell mit
wie es den i dem land genau handhabt ihr
das den blog bietet und dass in sachen
enthalten sind alle rechte ja wir sind
so richtig angespannt da ist die einzige
branche wo schaffen und die biener geld
verliert im moment als ich wirklich
dramatisch wir müssten jetzt der
kurzarbeit sofort können umsetzen zu
müssen personalkosten arbeits fahrer
aber da ist schlichtweg nicht trotz
denke jetzt so lange mir quasi die
arbeit für die bunte erledigte und
versuche die schweizerinnen und
schweizer wie sich hunde teils hole mir
ist ein betrieb nicht auto fahren
wie lange wohl der herzlich und normal
also eben jetzt mal kurz zurück wenn sie
das brot nicht nur solisten
[Musik]
gastro unternehmerin meter hildebrand
ist jetzt zu hause mit 75 kilo mehl aus
dem restaurant mix mit quarantäne und
kritische machen wir das gerade sommer
aber bedingung aber es bei adidas mit
dem entsprachen dann jemand rat werde
dann müsse mir bei mir sie sind und
brauchst du ja auch sein und wurde doch
das machen und die erste arbeit monopoly
gespielt und kräfte mit einer situation
ein komplett und so ist das buchprojekt
taxi zeigt sehr witzig entstanden
und ja ich meine es trotzdem irgendwie
gut und mir lachend und so überhaupt
nicht lustig aber irgendwie muss man
arbeitslos machen und da mal merken wir
machen jetzt brot und da sie große
mengen verschenken die den youtube
machen ihnen eine freude und darum aka
business trug sondern schlichtweg
elitesport freude - auch im napa größere
partner und höhere durchsätze ganz so
viel frage aber noch nicht beantwortet
sind mir einfach noch eine woche wartet
und in einer woche wisse man ihm es ist
völlig klar
der bundesrat hat von zahlreichen
berührenden schicksalen gehört und
gelesen
wir arbeiten tag und nacht um zu helfen
was wir der ganzen bevölkerung aber auch
sagen und eindringlich sagen wir lassen
euch nicht allein
wir kümmern uns um euch
zu ambiente groß kaiser hat mir macht
zur passiere mache
wo sind denn programm denn die zwei
milliarden a wurde und jetzt wo das
start ins motor vorgestellt so da
ungewisse dennoch probiert und probiert
bist mache erreiche man schon fast als
frau am telefon mit alle mieter
situation überfordert sind
[Musik]
die selbstständige cafés zahlt allein
für ihre wohnung und ihren laden mehr
als 2000 franken monatsmiete auf dem
konto vielleicht die sich franke
zwar liegt die zahl im versicherungsfall
es tut mir leid ich alle zahlenwerke
will zum zahlen aber ich kann nicht
enttäuscht
ein punkt war nicht schlafen
[Musik]
ich bin sehr sehr traurig ja nicht
zuletzt brille
sie lachen so langen und weise die man
machen kann ohne brille daniel koch ist
gast in der arena sendung den job ja
dass ich noch negativer als ich mich ob
mein job ist sollte das mit dem corona
videos möglichst gute betonte kann dicht
bevölkerten wie ein patient vorstellen
technisch abzüge dass der patient war
jetzt irgendwo ne infektionen dass der
infektionsherd nicht generalisiert
möglichst unter kontrolle und und tipps
um die person wirklich gut und schloss
wieder zu hause geld
[Musik]
von kitas kann nur ich sie aber das ist
nie mehr vergeben heißt also länger bis
weg wichtiges mitglied ist das höchste
sehr
und jetzt muss ein minister der
steuerung hat dort abstellen eigentlich
wäre daniel koch in ein paar tagen in
pension gegangen
[Musik]
ja das war wirklich aber ich denke ja
das war der fall wenn ich jetzt nicht
ganz bis 8
eine sport mit dem ruhm und redest du
also wenn ich jetzt die letzte tag
natürlich nicht und jetzt die woche an
der messe und der holt kam mir das
schwimmen kann
ob er ein brutales und iconica
trainieren
ja
[Musik]
regional spital affoltern am albis
besucher stopp auch hier wegen corona
arzt markus minder auf visite beim
schwer krebskranken konrad osterwalder
er leidet besonders unter der isolierung
[Musik]
städte gefühl ist dass ich darf der
brauch es egal und sie darunter stand im
grab und so kommunizieren reicher wird
tag hat das kind als sie gut vermieten
meint besitzt die für mich dass ich eine
quelle mit dem großen phantasie weil das
ein großer wunsch dass sie dass links
auch profit 19 patienten sind hier
hospitalisiert das regionalspital vor
wenigen wochen von manchen auch als
überflüssig erachtet ist jetzt wieder
wichtig dass die teamführung
allen respekt ab november oder das ist
quatsch die heutige medizin hat das
dreiteilung nicht drinnen im griff harry
gier ist mittlerweile wieder gesund zu
hause
beckys 6 uhr morgens adrian steiner
geschäftsführer der firma thermo planen
sie die möglichkeit ihr plötzlich
forschung zum thema corona auch die
angst und den betrieb also wieder an das
ist kein tunnel stand ja immer den
ansturm
das ist wohl gefallen ich habe freunde
und ich trage damit ihr werdet sie
taugen beschrieben sie mich weniger als
webber
also wenn ich merke dass ich praktisch
aufrecht merken dass ich auch sprachen
mit der frauen in der bereichsleiter
terminplan das unternehmen in der
innerschweiz produziert für den
weltmarkt
[Musik]
kaffeemaschinen für marken wie starbucks
und nespresso werden hier gefertigt das
kaffeetrinken italiens fabriken sind zu
und von dort stammen viele teile der
produktion ins beschauliche maschine
linie ich sage das dauert
[Applaus]
wenn dieses wochenende von der nachricht
der bogestra italien und der szene ist
recht anspruchsvoll
das ist einfach gerecht geschrieben dass
sie draußen und probiere die betroffene
verwandte zu erreichen
ob ich das natürlich schwierig diese mit
den eigenbetrieben und julian schwierig
schwiegermutter ist immer noch geprägt
sie 400 angestellte arbeiten hier
guten morgen
[Musik]
hallo
15 prozent der belegschaft fehle vor
allem mitarbeitende die zu den
risikogruppen gehören
ja ich muss sagen mir sein englisch oder
für betreiber hat immer mit nicht
beanstandet er weiß auch hier schaut man
was es so neues gmbh freut sich auf den
gedanken machen wie sie zukunft wie
sieht es mit dem plan steht viele offene
frage wie man muss auf die buchstaben um
die meisterschaft im kopf also die
mannschaft also nicht der fahrer jetzt
positive studie der stromer hat
persönlich und bezieht von ich mir schon
gedanken machen würde ich mir wenn ich
da heißt und
ein mitarbeiter habe das virus im
österreichischen skiort ischgl
aufgelesen sagt adrian steiner
unterdessen sei er wieder gesund und
arbeite im home-office aber
offensichtlich die produktion in der
montagehalle so das ist just als sich
die mitarbeiter komponenten heirat zu
montieren und somit setze ich dir
produktions mitarbeitende in einer größe
erfahrung dass das beschäftigung mehr
und das heißt was überlegen mit eine
situation wo man sein foto zulieferer
von italien das dass seine musik vor der
produktion im wallis 10 orientieren
überlegen sie sich nur so proaktiv zu
mitarbeiter schützen
ich schaue eigentlich sparen indem es
gegen zwei wichtige schlüssiger
verlängern sagte mir dass ich weiß es
nicht
das war eine situation auf der anders
ist und genau diese ignorierten rasch
konkrete kosten lassen
ich spüre sie oftmals bei mir aber wenn
sie so eine kumulierung von
verschiedenen sache geht und da als 1000
sagte baumann ist so entspannt und und
super positiv
[Musik]
aber das mache ich das jetzt die
schwierigste phase wo sie haben die cdu
chefin
[Musik]
was ist das jetzt merke dass gesundheit
und wirtschaft verschmerzt in der krise
dass das ist außergewöhnlich aber jetzt
mit skypen mit seinem chinesischen
partner ohne das kann ich nirgendwo
hingehen
du bist grün grün heißt dass ich nie an
einem gefährlichen ort gehen wenn ich
nachts lpg wird es gelb dann muss ich 14
tage zu hause bleiben
sehr konsequent wir sind überwältigt von
den ereignissen in italien leben
schwierige zeiten weil wir viel weniger
schnell handeln verglichen mit das ist
keine normale krankheit sie ist sehr
leicht übertragbar
schlägst du four soll ich die firma
schließen
ich empfehle euch halbiert die
belegschaft 50 prozent im betrieb 50
prozent zu hause und nach zwei wochen
wechseln
der markt fordert opportunities
und daraus hat sich jetzt auch nicht so
850 franken müssen mit einer optimierung
mann gemacht in die letzte jahr mehrheit
nicht kapazität verteilt in der heimat
sein dass produktivität wird fast
achteinhalb aus
maschinen für den großkunden starbucks
doch aus den usa die nächste
hiobsbotschaft
starbucks muss filialen schließen ist
die gesundheitsbehörde national
organisiert chh auf kommunaler ebene
darum ist alles unklar
das macht das noch viel komplizierter
fokussiert die durch eigentlich im
pazifik also begriffe aus marktlogik das
hier da dass die produktionskapazität um
rechts für domenico reservierten
vorsorglich ihre soli die plage aus
amerika im liefere haltestelle gecancelt
tendenziell seitwärts nachdem
sprachniveaus co
[Musik]
massimo bund sie hat inzwischen
umgestellt auf take away
[Musik]
die leute glauben die ganze familie
hilft dass ich schon schwierig schwierig
zusammen
frage ich weiß im moment geht um zahlen
der berswordt kurzarbeit betroffen
alle konnten die sozialen menschenrechte
vom glück haben wir gut gearbeitet in
die akten zum luca will wieder von luke
schade dass es so schlimm
der monat ist sie gerade millionen
weniger umsatz
[Musik]
und dass wir alle zusammen hatte
heute war kein einziger kunde 0
[Musik]
was wir heute erfahren haben aus dem
tessin ist es wirklich dramatisch sie
kämpfen jetzt genügend intensivbetten
station zu haben über 60 jährige wissen
dass das virus im moment sich weiter
verbreitet deshalb haben wir heute
morgen beschlossen die sozialen kontakte
weiter einzuschränken um die ausbreitung
des virus zu bremsen
beim ausatmen die damen und herren
werden die spontanen versammlungen von
mehr als fünf personen im öffentlichen
raum verboten im gesamten land spontan
das heißt die sportart ist doch einfach
unter kontakt
ich kann sich das einzige aber jetzt
nichts ausgangssperre
doch das gab es etwas mehr machen also
na ja das bringt und der bundesrat wählt
wenn immer möglich will keine
ausgangssperre für die schweiz zu
unserer freiheit georgiens auch die
bewegungsfreiheit aber dafür brauchen
wir das die ganze bevölkerung jetzt mit
macht das muss ganz ehrlich sagen
eigentlich schlimme härte und aber ich
liebe es sie von der schweizer erwartet
also mein es passiert sie drei wochen
liegt sind immer nur busse und jetzt
hätten möglichkeit kurz tage lud blieb
einfach politiker als halber beschränkte
fünf personen aus mainz 50 sind aber
noch 25 das lässt als das problem der
artikel handle
daniel cox hunde sind zurück aus dem
hunde hort
[Musik]
sie helfen natürliche krise will muss
nicht nur spazieren und habe es einige
wochen
[Musik]
kurz vor der krise hatte sich noch eine
weitere hündin gekauft und drückte noch
nie erzählt die handlung wird die arbeit
erschweren oder strom ziehen
daniel koch jahre lang arbeitete er in
afrika als ikk delegierter unter anderem
in sierra leone während des bürgerkriegs
zurück in der schweiz kämpfte er gegen
die sars pandemie
und jetzt plötzlich steht er im
rampenlicht
ja ich natürlich lumpur und hatte
plötzlich so viel aufmerksamkeit auf die
toilette und kommt ja es wird nicht
immer nur die gleichen fragen muss man
halt neue standort der neuen sechs jahre
ich glaube es wohl wichtigste ich
wirklich dass bevölkerung weiß um was
das geld ich glaube series unzählige
krankheiten die sie getankt nicht so
häufig und dass es jetzt so stark dass
ich vielleicht wieder einmal nach ich
sehe mich als schweizer
ich danke natur hält immer wieder
überraschungen parat und jedes land jede
gesellschaft muss mit dem problem um gas
sowie dem land und der gesellschaft
entspricht und mit probiere sowieso
schweizer des jahres machen elite klare
das heißt nicht extrem sie und probiere
zusammen mit der bevölkerung die
situation möchte
nicht nutzen mit ersten prozent
der stuttgarter am zustand von chávez
sei bestens gesorgt ist
das wird auch zeit
das ist einfach so ein moment
blumen zum bio nicht aus um genug
sauerstoff aufzunehmen und das ist nicht
gut für ihr herz wollen sie da ja auch
eine krankheit nach längerer zeit und
der ort möglich wahnsinnig schwieriges
problem ist einfach luft den patienten
netz bringen
das kann man mit sehr viel gewalt
sondern man muss dass das so schonend
und nachher das mit blumen nicht
zusätzlich durch schattige und das ist
schlussendlich aber schwierig
ich glaube es läuft gut es sind sehr
viele maschine gerade
diverse aufgabe machen und es ist ein
bisschen schwierig zu koordinieren wir
was übernehmen soll aber ich glaube dass
regel sich jetzt gerade alles des
pendels ich jetzt gerade ein also
vorsichtig zuversichtlich vorsichtig zur
versicherung
wir haben weiterhin steigende fallzahlen
es sind jetzt 8000 positiv getestet
worden und seit es schon 70 personen
verstorben
anne frank und zwar bin ich barfuß und
weiß mit genau wann ich es mache sinn
mache sein
ungefragt sollte hoffentlich von
kurzarbeit eventuell profitiert
veganer entschädigung raus bekommen ab 1
für formell das anime oder 0 2 noch
nicht nein noch nicht klar ob möglich
über kurzarbeiter okay da heißt für mich
konkret abwarten und tee trinken
70 eigentlich abwarten tee trinken
das beste draus gemacht wird grusel und
die lehre primarschule uster einzig
schulleiter ernesto harder und ein
mitarbeiter sind noch hier
sie bereiten laptops zur ausleihe vor
anja kaufhold zusammen mit ihrem sohn
einen laptop ab
weilburg kommt in schwung kommt
nur der brite kommt wenn die katholikin
und sich so schwierig sich zu motivieren
über stunden das vertrauen
mama dina denken etwas anfangen oder
nachspiel vor der hauptstadt
aber manchmal ist mir ja manchmal muss
mir die arbeit
[Musik]
es baut nachricht geschickt und muss ich
habe zwei drei sachen der ausdruck bald
muss die pflegefachfrauen wieder ins
spital zur arbeit
der an zwölf stunden schichten oder hört
sehr angespannt
[Musik]
hier finden sie sind viel zu wenig das
macht mir sorgen weil dieser krise sein
comeback ist es mit aller energie dritte
am vordereingang jetzt sehr viel
häufiger geben dass ganz nach vorn
ich konnte mit seinen kollegen tischten
ist die stadt aber jetzt dafür natürlich
nicht
das weiß die sehr stolz ist er schon
[Musik]
schlecker will das objekt doch oder
schießen
ja sie sind immer da und das ist schon
kompliziert beschleunigt
teenage zeit für dich wenn alles
zusammen sein zu sprechen stritten und
in der streitenden sowie muss er gemüse
polizei sei sein job sei
krankenschwester und dann ist alles
zusammen ist es gibt keine tabus sowie
muss lernen schnell
[Musik]
dazu dass etwas gut von dem was ist gut
was ist nicht gut
es gibt keine chance weg zueinander
alternativ muss irrt das ist sehr gut
ich glaube das ist für uns ist beste
die zehn milliarden die der bundesrat
bereits gesprochen hat sind als
soforthilfe zu verstehen
der bundesrat weiss dass es noch mehr
mittel brauchen wird der bund stellt 20
milliarden kredite zur verfügung für
bürgschaften über 40 milliarden franken
das ist die summe die im moment für die
betroffenen menschen und die wirtschaft
in der schweiz zur verfügung stehen
jacques lemans dass man weiß es wird
eine kurve und 60 tagesziel
also ich schätze mal damit mir eine
decke oder höflichkeit
ich probiere so gut wie möglich aus der
alltag irgendwie partei und damit auch
irgendwo in global tech i heißt eine
scharfe mega gern da fällt mir mega
unter kontakt mit dem lied es ist halt
wirklich typisch mehr oder weniger und
nur die high und du musst da irgendwie
zieht deutschland ja alles gut ich weiß
nich wahr machen wenn und wenn david
goldmoney mehr alles neu wieder kassiert
zweimal stelle
[Musik]
zwischen lehrerin melanie marti und
ihrer fünften primarklasse in uster
liegen 20 kilometer
[Musik]
was muss man gut trennen
das drei monats ihr ehemann ebenfalls im
home office kommt ihr zu hilfe
[Musik]
das wird jetzt noch als bestehende
barriere befördert die ganze heute sehen
es ist praktisch so unterstützt wird ja
dank dann immer darum wurden die ordnung
eltern war das nicht an
[Gelächter]
zusätzlich gab es ja die trickserie und
hebt die hand ich kann mich gerne sieht
die kinder von containern blut floss
stellen
und ich glaube das hat die eindruck
macht uns verändern und offener hörte
ich glaube was sicher hilft ist beim
regen war das mittelland zum miteinander
telefonieren am rande sieht also dass
ich wirklich davon sogar täglich apps
wie mir macht das ist wirklich aber nie
für sex touren machen einen computer mit
allerlei wie das momentan nicht alle
finden wie schon beschrieben sind
anteile von über vier sekunden
installieren
als ich schon bin ich völlig baff wie
das entweder sind oder delta reichenhall
verzogen die programme installieren zum
word-dokument abspeichern und aus per
mail schicken
das ist natürlich schon irgendwie toll
fand einmal nicht warten bis der bauch
für die heimischen liga die heim und
warte bis mir liegen die briten den biss
von mir
[Musik]
unser auftrag ist der patienten jetzt
testen
also wir sind sehr dankbar für die
existenz der schweizer armee wir herrn
grüne personal vom unispital
zurückziehen weil sie eins zu eins
ersetzt wird durch die so bereit
auch anderswo sind die soldaten im
einsatz spezielle schutzmaßnahmen mit
der hygiene maßnahme ist normal ein
hitler steckte 1 1 gebracht und in die
arbeit des pflegepersonals sieht er nun
mit anderen augen
also mit der frage wie sich
das merkt man sofort an der wegscheide
organisatorisches völlig anders ablaufen
und jetzt für douglas dass das ein genie
satz ist motivation von der soldat ist
viel höherer kameradschaft ist nun mal
größer sich markus terminplan weg ist
[Musik]
für geschäftsführer adrian steiner ist
nicht mehr der lock down in italien das
große problem sondern die lage im
eigenen betrieb mit hemd weiteren
verdachtsfall mehrproduktion die person
ist eingerichtet wurde und heute laufend
weiter mit dem büro ob sie positiv oder
man hoffe natürlich negativ ist jeden
tag veränderte ausgangslage und durch
sehr anspruchsvoll fürs ganze team für
die organisation
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum mittwoch update
zur krone sportlich scheint entwicklung
von der ausstellungs fall definition
wenn du immer schwierig in betracht
ziehe ich so dass wenn man innerhalb von
einer woche drei gestartet die frau hält
oder als stream auf garantien mit einer
person in kontakt sie sind und so weiter
und so fort das würde sie zum großen
teil die tracht ihrer produktivität weil
ich finde es gut dass sich die 3
bis 10 und schließlich es war ein
vollbad mit der musik rüthen d2
überreagiert oder anders gesagt jetzt
nur showroom animierte gefällt das sind
jetzt kapuze trug sich mit tritten von
fans seid ja kaffee sammlung über fünf
personen konnten das überhaupt oder
setze mir nützt da schon mal risiko raus
hin zur 8 aber die unsicherheit dass mir
macht das haus stehe macht das jetzt
weniger ausstattung das unternehmen
dafür jetzt stellt sich natürlich spüren
moskau
gespielt wird das minimum belastet und
wann ist auch gott und meine frau ist
sicher vorsichtiger anruf bei der bea
die hotline er will klarheit über
sitzungen in zeiten von corona
2 es kommt es zunehmenden
informationsbedarf haben wir derzeit
viele anrufe und elektro liegen für die
wartezeit in der schweiz im befriedigung
zu beginn ein computer anzuschließen
[Musik]
er geht zu den mitarbeitern von alessio
dem mann mit verdacht auf corona unita
brauchst dich das ich bin mit
risikogruppen generation
und ja wir sind nicht mit einer einsamen
stunden auch so wie heute
steiner will erst alle informieren wenn
ein verdachtsfall positiv getestet ist
und dafür zahlen entscheiden wo das rad
stand in sachen boni also der
mitarbeiter des eigentlichen entscheide
ob das gefühl hat es ist für mich besser
blieb die hausberger interessant sie als
25 personen
die gruppe hat mit größe sie dass das
areal für 70 ist die hauptsache
[Musik]
dann ein anruf der personalchefin
besucher ist sie uns kontaktieren
er gehört inzwischen zum vormittag
gesprächen mit den anderen mitarbeitern
vor der forschung entwicklung trage
jetzt symptom hält und mögliche
zahlungsmittel heimisch und dem zahltag
container das hinter frau und zwilling
hätte verschieben
der test ist noch nicht angeordnet wurde
[Musik]
wenn man das hier mit dem informieren
und kommunizieren der väter des
kommunizierens bestätigt ist
die personalchefin meldet sich erneut
gott sei dank ist alles teil und dann
auch und aber er die theorie und
diskutierten mit diesen themen überhaupt
ist auch mental muss nach hause in der
lage machen wie so weiter wie gehabt
also positiv ist negativ negativ ist
super
[Musik]
der flügeltürer das be ok das ist dass
ich mir rote faden und nie ja im kreis
höxter auch und setzte august rau dass
ich das ist eine bühne
ob großmann ist nicht einfach in kontakt
mit dem sie sind
[Musik]
bitte bleibt zuhause es würde auch für
alle gut sein dass für einmal ein jahr
es gibt kein stau am gotthard tunnel
dieses jahr musste
im moment sind 280 patienten unter einem
beatmungsgerät
das ist für einen schweiz doch enorm
viel wenn man sich das vorstellt das
sind 280 patienten die mit leben kämpfen
und hunderte von pflegenden die das
ermöglichen
[Musik]
alle bereit 90° 123
28 märz ich bin's kartoffelhof onyx die
patienten ganz legal
die hand fest
sie auf der intensivstation
also sind sehr rau steigen die zeiten
immer man das ist wirklich so die
patienten sind sehr sehr instabil sehr
sehr aufwändig der reanimation konnte
zum glück bis im moment erfolgreich fms
auf europa ihre oft intensivstation an
der gleichzeitigen ii lag versonnen
externen anführungszeichen sind extrem
am rotieren
weil ich jetzt noch nicht
bruckner c
[Musik]
wir haben weiterhin grund stand
steigende zahlen
das ist das typische welt patient in
bauchlage teilweise wirklich schwierig
zugeordneten braucht sehr viel aufwand
sehr viel pflege aber meistens hilft das
auch viel wenn sie eine talsohle
durchschritten wegen einfach akzeptieren
und zu erhalten braucht es sehr sehr
viele psychische kraft und ressourcen
fallen nachdem wir jetzt zu erheben und
auch irgendwann wie cds pcs kurze fragen
wenn der nachwuchs im kantonsspital chur
zurück und haben von 100% rosbergs
problemen und fragen wo immer man
braucht es gar nicht freuen wenn wir 1
und übernahmen
ich habe grosse kantonale motto juli
oder etwa sie nicht typischer mittäter
in kontakt ok es wird kompliziert
wir erwarten auch mehr patienten
wahrscheinlich habe anfang nächste woche
und es wäre natürlich gut mit testlauf
zu haben um zu schauen ob wir auch dort
alles parat haben was wir vorbereitet
haben
[Musik]
wir haben aber ein riesen glück im
kanton zürich die peripheren speziell
die machen wirklich eine gute weil die
übernehmen sehr viele patienten und wenn
wir das nicht so hätten hätten wir es
wahrscheinlich ganz andere zustände hier
am uni spital
die helfen uns sehr und da bin ich sehr
dankbar
im moment sind die zahlen stabil und ich
hoffe sehr dass es so beliebt vor dem er
bietet avid aerial stetige bitte passt
sich auf liefert cdh halten sie die zwei
meter abstand die und könnte jetzt nicht
ganz so schöne tätergruppe fuß gefasst
oder der heimat wo niki lauda machen
sondern blieben unter sich
[Musik]
natus im oberwallis trauerfeier für
teenager
wegen corona dürfen nur zwölf personen
teilnehmen
[Musik]
die kirche mit 500 sitzplätzen ist
praktisch leer
im neuen spot des sohnes und des
heiligen geistes im norden von organe
hier wie immer voll war es trage wie der
vertrieb mit den gläubigern es wieder
sie enorm von ihnen all dies richtig und
hat
ich glaube das war's für porto in dieser
familie und öl in alle drei familien
jetzt abzeichnet ist dass niemand auch
ich warne hat spiele wie sie also dass
man jetzt in der maas fordert vorne
steht wie immer das verwaltung in der
bank verteilt sind es noch nacheinander
die zustände in der beratung sind
auseinander brechen oder mal in ordner
und das spiel endlich sind die ganze
wand lehnen das fehlt jetzt vor allem
gottfried faser stark dass man wirklich
glücklich spielt als tool familie für
sie einzig das sind zwar super league
der polit aber jetzt in diesem
augenblick für die familie bietet aber
ich weiß nicht physisch c
die trauerfeier wird per livestream
übertragen
wer nicht in die kirche darf kann im
internet dabei sein
[Musik]
auch das trauer essen entfällt
da sitzt man zusammen und meistens ist
um schluss der relativ und lässt sich
stimmig das ist er ist v wer sie im
labor und labor geht weiter das fällt
aber das feld das in china um ein entern
oder ur besetzung gab man sich als
familie meldet ins cosco friedlich oder
das mittagessen das falsche fach nicht
[Musik]
auch eugen becker leidet unter dem
alleinsein
[Musik]
alfa romeo
ganz schlimm ich habe das in ihr herz
der frau in pflege praktische der tag
die nüsse wir sind jetzt ein alter sich
jetzt 21 kekse und die wird er ins
körpergewebe frank kunden wie lange hat
sie dann hier die frage
er sieht einfach sich jetzt die sperre
ist mal sicher die zeit bis sie ganz
besonders vermisst jetzt muss ich sehe
was ist das wo man sie am meisten
vermissen
[Musik]
spitex mitarbeiterin anja schneider seit
ausbruch der korona pandemie hat sie
viel zu tun denn oft bleiben patienten
lieber zu hause statt zum arzt oder ins
krankenhaus zu gehen
und weil auch angehörige zu hause
bleiben müssen sind die spitex
mitarbeiterinnen vielfach die einzigen
die betroffene besucher buch hat mir
richtig weh man einerseits mit buch hat
für die umsetzung von der schutzmaßnahme
und andere sitzt sie mir ja häufig auch
die einzige direkte kontaktperson wird
wütend und sie scheut denen der
austausch mit machen wir nach all der
verband auf einmal fertig ist ein lang
für lüttich die fast totale isolation
wirklich große forderung war psychisch
belastend kasimir wird insbesondere
jetzt natürlich unterstützen
[Musik]
orange habe ich mir gleichgültig aber
bald und schwache entweder unter den
kommentaren oder hast du dank staun nein
danke sie mehr und jetzt eine zeit lang
hat sie mehr und tod mit einem zittern
neue gar nicht
naja
und das jetzt zum herberger
da im alterszentrum wohnt und ist das
setting wie schafe inneren frieden und
umsichtig
julian jenner und der richter nehmen was
ich brauche
ich glaube genau dass ich jetzt bin ich
froh dass sie sehen daran ist auch
nichts dass strömen und das wäre eine
farce
[Musik]
hendrik maat koordiniert eine gruppe von
jungen helfern
kürzlich wurde da ist der hit
ja aber ich konnte
schleich dich anbieter
[Musik]
ein liter
naja es ist weil wir zwei sache und kann
aber der rest macht ich glaube aber
fertig
[Musik]
pavillon und einem klassischen pop
gemischt
[Musik]
zwei mal mit meinem geld
dieses teilt stadtrat und nachhaltig
wenn 40 im moment was sich unter anderem
in der gruppe sind
[Musik]
das gefällt nicht wo erst richtig an
werke und mit einer sachlich und sand
und nebel zu animieren
das geld sparen
[Musik]
heute wird sich aus drei jahren war
gleich dann 45 sachen unserer aufsicht
und darüber wie papiergeld cups noch
wurden aber erst noch das was mich immer
gepusht
mit 23 meter die stadt bringt geholt ich
weiß bis zwei stunden mehr getroffen
[Musik]
zum video und xxx für das beratungs und
stürzt er ihr könnt zwischen dass der
general motors steht die open source
verwandelt wird umgebenes grad steilen
adrian steiner prüft eine neue idee
starboxx bereit war depressiv maschine
sondern glaubt nichts grad zurück und
hat stern tv technologie zu
unterschieden starbucks darauf dass ich
jetzt einen berg sky produziert haus
kühl das aus für die amerikanische
industrie pcs ist das eine wo nicht so
aber nichts geblieben
[Musik]
also die komponente gesetzt 50 grad ist
es vor dem soli für partner hidrive
vorgegeben
also diese intershop olli dittrich
gefühl das einzige was ewigen optimisten
auf jeden fall
[Musik]
dann ging es dann zum tor zum wohlstand
wenn wir so zeige aber medizinische
faktoren für andere sondern opel hat
eine mechanische teile ab das mache das
zu tun wofür komponenten tests anderer
zu den mieten verrückte idee auch nicht
gerade zum hals steht dann ist so so
dass die musik dazu geführt dass weg zu
fuß auf mitarbeiter im moment für die
mitarbeiter ist ein vorhaben das bild
für das turnier fiel und wenn du sagen
ich sehe jetzt thema in der seele
wir sind aus und nahmen an der
verantwortung und auch kein rot sah und
nur sondern ich also dass das kann ich
so was nicht nach und gebaut dass man
auch wenn man nur eins überaus
diskutiert und neue kreative aber die
option ziehen und ich will nicht dass er
so kommuniziert jährige unternahm
wir sind wird das ist auch klar sich nie
einfach in der krise aber so mancher
vermieter ausgesprochen
dann ruft der starbucks an
um es klar zu sagen es gibt immer noch
technische herausforderungen wir haben
nicht das wissen der medizinal industrie
haben wir ausgewählt
im scherz lange im terminplan ist die
eine pharmafirma ihr haltet euren
betrieb so sauber es sollte also einfach
sein das zertifikat zu erhalten
[Musik]
wer sich überlegt mir den schuh aus dem
hinspiel
die strahlung wird wird mehr gefragt ist
auch nix graz machen das ist ob ich sie
mache diese kaffeemaschine
aber wir wären aber landwirtschaft sich
so von der bedürfnisse von der
grundbedürfnis manche lebensretter
empfahl das geht ganz anderes in frage
oder daher schon gemacht also mehr als
ein paar gemacht wodurch der waldverlust
würde die globalisierte generell
hinterfragen
bis endlich sind jahre international
tätig europa sagt wolfhard ediger
optimiert oder jetzt sind auch noch
geboten zu haben und hat sich mit der
finanzkrise mit der schweizer franken
stärke und so wieder was ist passiert
manches eben weniger boote die marge
betrug oder und die hosting mit
effizienz das wunderschöne nord auf dem
jähriger im ganzen fluss senne und dass
man da natürlich steht und wo es noch
optimieren und das haben wir auch
gemacht
die maschen ich habe mir zurück und
jetzt holt süßes aus b27 wir selber
schon bei zwickau und für diese
produktion nicht nach geschrei optimiert
also ich bin überzeugt wir die csu aus
der krise
[Musik]
ostersamstag daniel koch unterwegs zur
medienkonferenz mit guten nachrichten
[Musik]
wenn sie so wie viel geld den hund gut
aber das hängt davon ab wie sich
bevölkerung wieder etwas haben und
erfolge halten
theoretisch könne die risikogruppe
portmonee zion oder wie ich denke dass
die krankheit mit euch nie die chance
dass jetzt nicht schwer krank ich
relativ gut
sicher nicht so dass es ganz dato
mischung mit johnny depp und denkt jetzt
wird die frauen
[Musik]
ich denke - flexibel sie flexibel im
sehen dass man ja nicht weiß wie schnell
zurück wie schnell das topspiel
traditionen zurück
als kassie das jetzt bei schönwetter und
so viel schlechter überschreitet das
virus und tasten viel weniger gesteckt
und dann muss man sich jede maßnahme
passen unterbruch zwischen flexibilität
[Musik]
sind wir also über den berg der kurve
hinaus
ja wenn wenn der berg der über den wir
sind der letzte berg halten sind wir
darüber hinaus im moment sieht es auch
gut aus muss man sagen aber es ist
sicher zu früh jetzt zu sagen alles
vorbei wir haben noch einen ziemlich
langen weg zu gehen
[Musik]
der chef ist was wir jetzt unbedingt
durch die erfolgserlebnisse will man die
sehr viel patient aber wirklichen leben
es ganz schwer verletzt haben und wenn
man dann schon verkauft abteilung dürft
ihr dann ist es schön
wir sind überschwemmt worden wie jetzt
welt schlagen das tessin maximum es
kribbelig vor 20 oder 21 patienten auf
der intensivstation und müsse so
weitergeht und die reserve station eine
macht werden
[Musik]
dass die viren index waren denen die
innerste schicht vor der kreis wenn das
die tiere befallen und als
schlussendlich zu der mikrozirkulation
stetige führten realen organen und damit
haben wir eigentlich erklärt warum und
das virus also problem auch die algen
er hat sich einfach nur probleme doch
schlussendlich haben therapieren
[Musik]
das mit anfahrt desto mehr volumen geben
der patientinnen und sich der brustkorb
dementsprechend aber erhebt und die luft
hier über der patient immer gedrückt
wird
faszinierend von der technik aber auch
sagen sich spitz war eine russische
puppen aber auch mercedes mit mit luft
mit schufa das ist sehr emotional
wer videos
und wenn ich deine angrenzendes
kaffeemaschine teil was sich die ganze
motorrad wind laut riegler in buchs bei
aarau mode oder aber auch raitenbuch sie
denn da immer noch versteckt sensoren
oder und sein sohn hier verschiedene
stühle dienten sie ja das thema das ist
ein echter ganzen land sie eben vor der
kaffeemaschine massen vor der
kaffeemaschine herrscht eine
kaffeemaschine
[Musik]
nach dieser 2001 konstrukt macht und
freue mich neue partner ich rosenkohl
mit starbucks zeit hatten wir keine
garantieren ja das gibt es zertifikate
frauen vom amerikanischen verkaufen
garantieren aber sehen das genau
aufzeigen dass wir es so machen sind
chance sehr groß
das ganze endlich zähler sie haben große
hoffnung dass das wirklichkeit
erinnerst du dich du hast mich
seinerzeit gefragt weshalb thermo planen
das ist genau der grund weshalb wir euch
angefragt haben
ihr seid unglaublich wie er das in so
kurzer zeit hingekriegt hat
vielen dank es hat spaß gemacht mit
teilen für kaffeemaschinen
beatmungsgeräte zu bauen
wir sind auch beeindruckt und es
funktioniert ein space shuttle der konto
könnten wir sein
starbucks wir könnten eine anzahl kaufen
und zum spenden wenn ihr einen adresse
habt können wie die geräte nächste woche
schicken wo nicht nur beethoven keine
ikone und hoffen dass mit den
komponenten hoffentlich gebiet kunden
auch die stange und hoffen natürlich
dass sich bis auf sichtweite
ich finde es gut wenn mal wieder ein
schwieriges problem hält also
es relativiert einige sei im umgang auch
immer aus team bilden und aber nach
fokussiert ihn richtig zusammen das
finde ich schön also ich finde eine
krise schön aber der effekt ist als
unternehmen nichts einbringt das schön
[Musik]
januar von peter smits problem und
schickt im großen segment durchschaut
dass maßnahmen gewirkt habe jetzt im
einzelnen sank zur schließlich gerät aus
bewegt
ich schließe nicht aus dass ich das ist
nicht möglich das wird schwierig sie im
nachhinein gesetz finde welche maßnahmen
genau welche möglichkeit wahr sich
zweifelsohne meister berichtet ist es
trüb vorarlberg antritt und distanz haye
konnte dass ich mit sicherheit die
größte sind mit sich heute größte effekt
[Musik]
ich glaube ich freue mich darauf das ist
billig und wenn das ziemlich natürlich
zeigt wirklich schnell
heute können wir feststellen
diese maßnahmen wirken die ausbreitung
des corona virus wurde gebremst und
unsere spitäler sind zurzeit nicht
überlastet das ist eine gute nachricht
nun können wir erste lockerungen
vorsehen
die lockerungen erfolgen schrittweise
mit dem ziel einen raschen anstieg von
infektionen zu vermeiden
man kann bei dieser epidemie eigentlich
keine verlässlichen prognosen machen
heute wissen wir nicht einmal ob wenn
jemand die krankheit durchgemacht hat
opel wirklich mittel oder längerfristig
geschützt ist aber nicht die krankheit
wieder bekommen kann
das sind einfach noch viel zu viele
fragen offen als dass man sich darauf
etwas festlegen sollte
lewitan rinne und liebe therme braun wie
sich das einige das freut klar ist wie
sich jene maske richtig platziert
solcher seiten immer noch da 4
[Musik]
zufällig über mund und nase
also ich für jede meereis und 8
das war das persönliche leid
ich hoffe ich habe das restaurant und
widerrufen ist super wie bezogen hallo
wie genau und kind mit dem schulhof zu
machen
jetzt anschauen sind zahlen die durch
zwei teilbar sich gegenseitig wieder
sehr gern zum znacht die lassen
wenn das alles so wie ich und das
sächsische lieferumfang und gegen klappt
das ja langweilig
warte auf bessere zeiten ich hoffe du
glaubst es ja schallt der hahn kräht der
virus
heute im fall ja
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von br genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
der camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922